Cela dit, ils iront voter
demain.
Plusieurs devront s'armer de
patience parce qu'il manquera de
personnel dans une dizaine de
circonscriptions Québec.
- D'ici quelques heures,
les électeurs s'attrouperont
devant les bureaux de vote.
Le quart d'entre eux ont
déjà voté par anticipation,
un record.
Les 4 760 000 autres électeurs
devront voter à partir
de 9 h 30 lundi.
Après 36 jours de campagne,
qu'en pensent les électeurs?
- Ha! ha! Il était temps
que ça finisse. On savait qui
était gagnant dès le départ.
Ça fait que, là, toutes
les promesses et tout ça,
c'était comme du vide, là.
(soupir)
- Pour ne pas pleurer,
je l'ai trouvé drôle.
Alors, c'est pas gentil ce que
je suis en train de dire.
- Plusieurs électeurs reprochent
le manque de propositions
crédibles, à tel point que
cet homme n'ira pas voter,
lui qui a pourtant l'habitude
de le faire.
- Ah, là, on fait ce qu'on veut.
Il y en a un qui dit "Je vous
donne 600 $", l'autre qui dit
"Non, moi je vous donne 800".
Le prochain va dire 1000...
Aux enchères, on y va.
- Ce père n'a pas été convaincu
par les partis.
- Il y avait très peu de
propositions intelligentes qui
ont été faites malheureusement.
Et puis aussi un certain
fatalisme, parce que l'issue
est connue depuis le début
de la campagne.
- Au marché public de Rimouski,t
envers la campagne. Un château
fort péquiste pourrait tomber.
- Je pense aussi que ça va être
serré en effet. Il y a le même
parti qui rentre depuis
quelques années ici à Rimouski.
Puis je pense que cette année
ça va peut-être changer.
- J'ai trouvé que c'était
une campagne... Ça va être
du nouveau. C'est tout du
nouveau monde, ça fait que
ça va faire un changement.
- De l'ombre au tableau pour
la journée des élections :
les bureaux de vote de11 circont
de personnel. Principalement
en Montérégie, Lanaudière
et l'île de Montréal.
PIERRE REID,
directeur général des élections
- Même s'il y a une file
d'attente, là, à 20 h,
les gens qui seront en file
à 20 h pourront voter.
- Le directeur général
des élections veut rassurer
la population : peu importe
e de personnel,
les gens auront accès lundi
à leurs bureaux de vote
dans toutes les circonscript
du Québec. Il demande d'avoir
en main son avis d'inscription
et sa pièce d'identité pour
faciliter l'une des étapes
les plus importantes
de notre démocratie.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Co
Radio-Canada, Mon